[Music]
hi I'm Tina husband say and the
molecular biology reporter for science
news magazine CRISPR is a hot new
molecular biology tool that you may have
heard of because everybody is using it
to edit genomes to fix genes and break
genes do all kinds of things
CRISPR started out as a bacterial
defense system bed sniffs out viruses
and chop them up into little pieces but
some very clever scientists have
re-engineered the molecule so you can
search out specific genes and change
them according to most scientists CRISPR
can do anything but it's not exactly
true but it can do a lot of stuff
they've already used it to create more
muscular beagles to repaint the wings on
butterflies to create a mushroom that
doesn't Brown when you cut it and even
to re-engineer some immune cells so they
go and kill tumor cells in cancer so
CRISPR is currently mostly a research
tool but it's starting to get into
helping people in 2017 you can expect
for instance to see clinical trials for
cancer
starting out with CRISPR and also
possibly bringing CRISPR back to its
roots to combat viruses like HIV and
hepatitis
there's a question about whether using
CRISPR is ethical in a lot of different
situations on the one hand you have the
problem of engineering designer babies
perhaps by changing their teens with
CRISPR and a lot of people are really
uncomfortable with that but even if you
just limit it to curing diseases for
instance some people may not be able to
afford a CRISPR therapy so you have to
decide who should have access how much
should it cost a lot of might be is
concerned with on the one hand we can do
all these incredible things with tools
like CRISPR but on the other hand should
we really do them
[Music]